I really like this clip I'm gonna play
for you today remember back when it
leaked that Donald Trump referred to
countries not like Norway presumably
countries with brown and black people
including African countries as [ __ ]
countries and I can say that now because
the president has said it and how Trump
doesn't want them coming to the United
States but he would just love to bring
people from countries like Norway to the
United States as immigrants and the
meeting that this was said in was about
immigrants from Haiti El Salvador and
some African countries Trump later
denied having said anything negative
about Haitians but he never denied
calling African countries [ __ ]
countries this is just the best Trump
recently hosted the Nigerian President
Muhammadu Buhari at the White House and
they did one of those news conferences
outside the White House where a press
corps takes turn takes turns asking
questions to Bihari and the Trump and
the Nigerian leader was asked if he and
Trump discussed that time when Trump
used quote vulgar language the reporter
didn't say when Trump called African
countries [ __ ] countries but when
Trump used vulgar language to describe
African nations and it was as good as
you can imagine Buhari is a real
diplomat he dodged the question very
professionally he questioned whether
that is even something that has been
confirmed because he didn't hear Trump
say it and he basically gives Trump and
out and remember the question wasn't to
Trump Trump chooses to jump in and say
we didn't discuss it but basically
restates that he stands by the comments
that he is accused of having made take a
look at this clip Denis Buhari I want to
ask you you're the first leader from
sub-saharan Africa to visit President
Trump here at the White House did you
address his reported comments from
earlier this year when he reportedly
used vulgar language to describe African
nations well I'm very careful with good
time
the princess about other than myself
right I'm not sure about you know the
validity or whether that allegation
against the present was true or not so
the best thing for me is to keep quiet
we didn't discuss it and you do have
some countries that are in very bad
shape and very tough places to live in
but we didn't discuss it because the
president knows me and he knows where
I'm coming from and I appreciate where
we did not discuss it
mr. president you can ask a question
that is just the best we didn't discuss
it and listen there are [ __ ]
countries in Africa so there's really
nothing to discuss this is more of an
admission that Trump did say it right
and it's very interesting to me watching
a skilled diplomat next to trump the
Nigerian president clearly a skilled
diplomat gives everybody an out right by
saying I don't know what was said and at
that point they could have moved on and
Trump chooses to jump in answer a
question that wasn't directed at him and
ends up once again lending the story
more credibility the Nigerian
president's answer was nuanced it was
tactful and Trump just fell for it
completely and there's also this very
ignorant American perspective that Trump
espouses when he says things to the
again the Nigerian president you do have
some really tough countries that are in
bad shape
as if that has anything to do with the
Nigerian president who's president of
Nigeria right like aside from this
entire thing being sort of silly
Africa's huge and mentioning to the
Nigerian president that you do have some
tough countries in Africa it's like
saying to the Mexican president that
there are some really tough countries in
South America what on earth does he have
to do with that or saying to Justin
Trudeau that the Americas really have
some difficult countries Nigeria in the
context of Africa is actually doing
quite well not that Trump would
necessarily know that and the idea that
President Buhari has a connection to or
sort of like representation of the poor
or more desperate areas is pretty silly
and it's just part of that hyper
normalization we've been talking about
we're used to the inappropriate behavior
to such
agree even this little detail like can
you imagine another president saying to
the Nigerian president that their
[ __ ] Country comment was logical
because listen the continent that you're
from has some really difficult places on
it and I also by the way we don't get to
talk about African politics that often
but I'm actually really interested in
African politics there's a new UN report
that projects that by 2050 Nigeria will
be the third most populous country on
the planet and I am very interested in
the potential future of Nigeria as a
world power house there is also the
question of oil drilling in the future
of Nigeria and I think it'll be very
very interesting to see Africa an
African country experience sort of a
mega growth period the way that China
and India have so I actually I know we
don't get a chance to talk about that
much on the program but Nigerian
politics and the Nigerian economy is
super interesting I assume Trump is not
really up to speed on them even now they
have a very large population I think
he's like a hundred and eighty million
people huge yeah and it goes to this
idea that Africa is just this big
amorphous thing I'm probably didn't
realize it was a continent yes and not a
country until just very recently yeah
which listen Sarah Palin also didn't
know that right didn't she refer to
Africa as a country and not a continent
I think that's that entire thing started
okay discuss this with us on our
subreddit if you so please at david
pakman.com slash re d di t next Jason
Murphy returns to the program to talk
about universal basic income we'll talk
about negative income tax rates we'll
talk about job guarantee programs great
great interview coming up with Jason
today's program is made possible in part
by fat or fat or is a social forecasting
game where you compete with other
players to predict the future and it's
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market a scientifically
proven way of using the wisdom of the
crowd to create more accurate
predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you can check out my predictions
and follow me to get updates on my
profile which is linked to in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube the tour is a great tool to find
out more about the world improve your
forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur comm sign up and start making
forecasts it's free and it's available
on both Android and iOS as well as on
web browsers and that's f you t you you
are calm